now your reaction
to the chris sims top 16 quarterback
list my primary objections are number
one drew brees at 10 number two patrick
mahomes nowhere to be seen other than
that
well other than that i still don't like
it
stats what are the people saying about
the chris sims quarterback list first
response that came in came from logan
miller he said this might be the worst
list i've ever seen more substantial
than that colton mitchell says i'm glad
to see that people seem to understand
that dak prescott cannot throw
accurately
well hey uh i you know i i don't know
what to say listen my qualifications in
this department are not bad okay and
listen i'm not saying that i have every
answer in the world but man i did grow
up around an nfl quarterback i played
the position i was kind of good i've
caught passes for guys like dan marino
and brett favre i've been on the field
with tom brady and peyton manning i've
been coached every day for five years
straight by john gruden uh let's see i
worked for new england patriots so i'm
just trying to be so sensitive no i'm
not being expensive but this isn't this
isn't let's share our resume with the
world we understand you're here for a
reason we get it you've got the chops
okay you're very defensive i know i i
wanted to share my resume
i wanted to share my resume with the
world i did that's exactly why i did it
thank you you may need to get your
resume together after this program
sorry damn i didn't know you're going to
fire me over it
at golf traveler bos says mvp at number
three lol amazing how much this guy
dislikes thomas why does everybody think
i hate tom brady why because i say he's
the third greatest quarterback of all
time oh my gosh i'm so mean and i'm what
a bad guy i am i mean hey first of all
this guy that's commented at golf
traveler sounds like you should be
watching golf and not worried about my
list okay you seem like more of an
expert on golf than quarterbacks leave
the quarterbacking to me
hey first of all kudos to using the
roger goodell's evil twin brother photo
of chris sims i think there's no more
appropriate time to use that photo than
today i i i really makes me mad that
people think i dislike tom brady i have
like four autographs in my possessions
and tom brady is one of them so what are
the other three uh michael jordan derek
jeter and i have a peyton manning
autograph
all right who's number two on your
all-time quarterback list number two
would be john elway all right solid
choice i know who number one is i mean
we don't even need to go down there we
don't need to don't waste our time go
ahead at lead tier says watson and
newton above carr wilson number two
insanity
carr
which car david are you kidding me i'll
i'll we'll defend you on that one chris
i think derek carr probably higher than
he should be on the list well you know i
i did i took this into account too let's
not forget derek carr was hurt last year
he did have a broken bone or fracture in
his lower back that he still played and
two years ago when the raiders went to
the playoffs i mean there's a good
chance he wins the mvp of football that
year if he doesn't get hurt at the end
of the season so no i think derek carr
deserves to be in the top 16.
at kev webb 1984 says and you have drew
brees ranked third in the nfc in the nfc
south with cam and ryan ahead yeah you
loco my friend i i understand that drew
brees is awesome but at the age of 39
yes i don't think he's the player that
those guys are he could still lead the
team to the super bowl and do special
things but that team is about their run
game first and i think sometimes when
people evaluate drew brees they have to
realize that sean payton is one of the
greatest offensive play callers and
designers in the history of the sport
and yes because of that uh it doesn't
matter what quarterback sometimes you
put in that offense they come out and
put up numbers i mean josh mccown
started for them a few years ago and the
year carolina went 15-1 not josh mccann
luke mccown he threw for 300 yards an
unbelievable completion percentage and
almost won the football game it's a
machine that offense so i docked drew
brees a few spots because of that
x talk 11 says you're an idiot to put
ben behind some of those names well i i
mean yes that's definitely a valid point
i could be an idiot i understand that uh
big ben
you know again
is awesome he's one of the greatest
throwers of the football i think big ben
is somewhat underrated in the all-time
rankings uh but no at this point of his
career i don't think he's quite as
quality as some of the guys in front of
him and not able to make some of the
plays off the cuff
that some of those guys can make
you know i'm looking at this list now
and and i wonder how it would compare to
the jaylen ramsey assessments of
quarterbacks a week ago it may not be
all that far off because you do have
matt ryan at number nine i mean i i told
you i agreed with a lot of what jalen
ramsey said there was a few i didn't and
then i thought he was a little political
on some of them but there was there was
a lot that i just shook my head and said
huh he's not that far off with him you
did leave off you did leave off marcus
mariota i know he's not quite up there
in that class yet he did throw 13
touchdowns and 15 interceptions last
year he you know so there's still room
to grow for him as a player he
definitely has potential to be a top 10
type of quarterback
you also left off jared goff i i know
and you know jared goff would be
somewhere around 20 or 21 he's a good
player he's still young but you know i
look at that and go man sean mcvay that
offense their leading pass receiver was
todd gurley that means it was a lot of
short passes and then a lot of running
by todd gurley i'm not going to give
jared goff the credit for all that did
you put jimmy garoppolo at 15 as a favor
to kyle shanahan no not at all
you know jimmy gara it's
a it's just you know a short sample size
but man jimmy garoppolo has been pretty
damn phenomenal whether it's starting
for the 49ers or the patriots uh in in
in that limited time
you